[Music]
you know a llama chicken-fried yeah I
see hey there's our new intro yeah hey
welcome to fraud I'm one of the hosts
here John rapist sitting to my right is
the lovely Sarah Tia oh I did not think
you were gonna say that word but okay oh
you're lovely thank you you're welcome
we're gonna pretend this is our first
time doing this because well we've done
a couple this is our this is our fake
first time doing our podcast we won't
this would be the first one you hear
yeah because we have a very special
guest yes and he couldn't call in but
this guy called you another guy yeah we
got another guy so Brad Paisley is on
the line hi Brad hi there so this your
first one of these no it's a it's the
first one we're gonna air because you
know we got it we're getting we got we
got you but we've done like five that
are like you know haven't come out yet
John is really good at talking yeah you
noticed yeah it's so yeah this is our
first one this is the first one that's
gonna air but we've recorded a bunch of
other ones and do you expect people to
listen to this I don't know what to
think people yeah we were hoping they
wouldn't we're hoping to listen to what
has he even called it it's just called
fried called fried it's just like a
southern podcast with me and read
because we have southern routes but he's
a little bit more southern than me so
he's teaching me more southern stuff and
I'm teaching him you know how to be a
lady book learning it comes out Fridays
comes out on Fridays and this one is
gonna come out the Friday before our
Netflix special airs yep oh great yeah
excited I'm I'm very excited I saw a
little preview of it somewhere yeah it's
called Brad Paisley's comedy rodeos when
did that name come about I love it
Netflix sort of I don't think I'm over
there or not but
they basically said we want something
that says that this is a bunch of things
like a bunch of people and sort of
country and that was their idea of it I
love it and it's two hours long is it
really right no it's not only it's two
hours okay I have no idea okay that's
like a little over 60 I think and then
how much how much of John set did you
cut out of it almost all of it basically
introduced John Reid he comes up and
then we like play a couple of chords
from riverbanks and he goodnight well I
like to just know that's the best part
of my set was when you were up there
yeah we kept it to the last good I mean
I you know me and John have had the
pleasure of working with you for three
years and it let me just say Bradley it
was so fun to watch the other comics
just be like completely and all with you
and how funny you are
I think Brad and I can be like well no I
think John and I've kind of taken it for
granted that you're this really funny
guy and we don't really think of how I
mean I feel like the country community
knows that you're really funny because
of the CMA Awards but and because of 20
songs funny songs but I mean I feel like
you are really known for a lot you're
known for a lot of songs maybe we'll cry
dude right oh yeah have this whole thing
come about for you like what did you
want to even jump into the comedy world
I don't know I kind of think I think
that it it came about because I've
always I've always sort of enjoyed
writing funny stuff the most I mean I
like I like writing songs that are
little sort of I guess three acts
comedies and that are you know they have
their you got your first first and then
you hook
in your second verse and then a bridge
and it's all very much sort of script
writing in some ways because the way to
cut your music is so descriptive and
then growing up and performing I learned
that you can get it's a lot more fun if
the stuff between songs is funny and
interesting like when you're talking I
quickly learned oh there's things
there's buttons you can push as opposed
to one of those performers that just
kind of thinks you know you you'll go to
see a performer and they just they think
they're interesting when they're talking
between songs and they're not yes oh
yeah and and it's always been
fascinating to me that that you know
some people are good at the banter and
some people aren't
and so I studied that quite a bit and it
was kind of a natural progression to say
let's try to do something where the
banter is the large portion of this as
opposed to just sort of a way between
songs and and great things that sort of
exists just to be that interesting thing
which is really what stand-up is mm-hmm
well I feel like you know so many times
in comedy I I've met a lot of musicians
who are fascinated with stand-up and a
lot of comics who are fascinated with
music and I feel like that's because
we're all trying to get a harness on
that that time between you know the time
between songs for you and the time
between jokes for us and also like man
there's so many times when I've been
doing stand-up where a joke doesn't work
and I'm like I wish I just had a guitar
yeah it's it's a really fascinating
thing because in in my line of work you
find yourself sort of thinking the
opposite like you're playing these songs
and you're thinking what am i what am I
going to do between these like I in
between the songs is is when they sort
of pay attention sort of the different
you know it's different it's sort of
like that's that's when you can really
score
and music because you really have like
they're not expecting much between songs
but if you're giving them something
really interesting between songs and
they really are that's just gravy
yeah they're just like this is and
that's why that's such a fun challenge
to be a part of any sort of stand-up
thing like this and I mean I really
think that people are ready for this
collision a little more you know when
you think about the artists that or do
you think about the comedians that
incorporate it like Demetri Martin he
doesn't necessarily ever do songs but
he's got that guitar in that harmonica
mm-hmm and so it it's just sort of like
Steven Wright jokes with guitar and
Steven Wright does that too like I've
seen him grab a guitar before and you
know and Steve Martin Hartley was first
do that with an instrument where the
instrument became some sort of
interesting it's almost like watch it
was like watching two different acts at
the same time I got a great banjo Claire
just Ryan got a guy up with an arrow
through his head yeah and and I think
that it's it's fascinating to me to
think about what could happen and we've
experimented before where you guys came
out to Hollywood Bowl and told jokes
between songs and and will now to a gig
or two that way and these large arenas
it's not going to take much for the
audience to get to where they're not
sort of wondering what's happening right
when they see comedians between you know
saying like people have tried it but if
we really ever got there like if this
Netflix special caught on people got to
know me a little more like this mm-hmm
it'd be really fun to to see it and we
can make comedy a little more of a part
of my tour than it already is
yeah because I feel I feel like that is
that is the one hurdle that I've had
when I'm promoting this special is that
they're like oh they're even giving Brad
Paisley a Netflix special now normally
you know how funny bread is and they're
like no and I'm like well then you just
wait like that's exactly what this is
really gonna showcase because I feel
like your core audience watches the CMAs
but maybe they've never they've never
seen you in this capacity and they
certainly haven't seen myself and John
and Nate and John Heffron and and Mike
you know in the capacity where we're all
singing it together onstage in the very
beginning that was fun yeah hey how did
I saw oh yeah I saw a little preview
with David David Hasselhoff well how is
he involved imperiously yeah yeah well
they wanted some sort of like intro
cold-open piece and so I like they were
they said would it be could it be cool
he grabbed some sort of celebrity or
somebody that has almost nothing to do
with this and see if they did they want
to like come up with a skit and so
Hasselhoff is in my latest video and I'd
gotten to tell him and you know he's
hilarious willing to you know let a goof
around and make fun of themselves at all
times he reminds me in some ways of
Shatner that way where it's sort of like
guys are legends and people weep when
they meet them and and yet he sort of
like you know what can I do that'll make
you laugh yeah and and so basically we
did a skit that opens the special it's
kind of be trying to get trying to get
to the to the event
I mean I'll have a ride and so I need
over or something and of course he we he
has a very specific car that's able to
take me you know and we just kind of
have a couple minors and stuff around
that like there's a there's a moment
when KITT pulls up and I look at him and
say where he said like you need a ride I
get you a ride you got like over or what
he's like and that pulls up and he's
like get in and I'm like do I need to
drive he's like no it'll just take you
there and we all it's like a Tesla well
I think there's like that's another
reason that I feel
like comedy hasn't exactly like really
pushed the limits in the country world
is because there's a lot of I feel like
country artists in some ways like maybe
older like a generation before us are
you know a little bit like Ashley it's
like they're not really able to take a
joke on themselves are very serious and
your when the first people I ever met
that was totally game with being made
fun of and you were gonna strike back
just as much but I always really admired
that about you do you feel like that's a
new wave of things that's coming in
country music where people are like
artists are more willing to make fun of
themselves I don't know I mean it
depends I mean it just there are artists
that doesn't work for mm-hm you know
like like their imaging is so much a
perder what what people sort of spend
their time trying to figure out when
they get a record deal they they want to
know like you know do you wear a hat you
know wear a hat are you known for that
you know like what kind of shirts are
you know you plaid shirts are you like
are you playing button downs you like
the ripped up t-shirt or you know how do
you our old shirts like you you were a
lot of really tight women's yes my
prince you know and so but imaging is
you know are you a tough guy and are you
okay you're known for and I don't know I
mean you know athletes some athletes are
that is as you both know comedies tough
it's it's more it's one of the hardest
things you can do and it's and one of
the reasons why you don't see a lot of
country singers doing it is that they
don't want to look foolish and maybe
rightfully so because I've certainly
done things that I regret in the name of
comedy but they don't they don't want to
look foolish and they don't want their
fans to like they want to bust their
bubble there and I know that they've
spent so long cultivating but when you
look at the sports world like one of the
best examples of the way it can pay
dividends to be willing to do this is
Payton yeah because you know and I just
got done filming
an entire fall sources nationwide
commercials with him and I have never
seen anything like his natural instincts
and ability to make fun of themselves he
like a whole premise of our commercials
is him coaching me thinking that he's an
expert because he's think this because
he sings jingle like he thinks he's
really good all that saloon you know
that's and that's it's persona in that
yeah and a lot of people would say well
I don't want to come off like that right
I don't want to look foolish I don't
know what I don't want you know here he
is like totally willing to do this and
get up and host the ESPYs and yeah you
know and and in that I don't know if
there's a new generation of country
singers willing to sort of because you
got to be willing to look foolish yeah I
think it's actually more it just makes
you more likeable you know if you're if
you're if you open yourself up that way
people that makes you more real I think
people are just also like an in comedy
we know that like self depth like you
have to make fun of yourself before you
can make fun of anybody else and but I
also think that like but when I look at
people like you and Peyton I mean
because you know I produce Peyton's bit
on the on the roast and I told him I was
like you know when people they're gonna
be making jokes about you if you if you
like the joke laugh if you hate it laugh
harder right because the perception of
you being able to take a joke is is way
more important and the jokes are going
to tell which is yeah we know Bieber's
image yeah exactly and people look at
you it's such a nervous thing like
people look at you like what do you
think and and and you're right I mean
that's the best advice you can give it's
like even if you hate it even if it's
off limits just mhm you better laugh you
go back and yell at your manager later
yeah why'd you let me get into that
situation what mmm-hmm you sure as hell
better laugh on the
I have to share this little quick story
with you the when I worked with you in
Beverly Hills for the when I met Shatner
okay he was yeah he was in the wings I
went him did like 20 minutes or
something and I came off and there was
William Shatner standing there and the
wings right behind the curtain he's got
his hands he's got his arms open like he
wants to hug me and I walk straight up
to him and I'm like we I guess for
Huggins and I just kind of reached in
and embraced him and his mouth was right
in my ear and he just said two words and
then that was all he goes what fun
what'd he say
what fun it's like he just saw me bun
yeah fine what fun mm-hmm there's just
there's he is a case study in living
yeah oh nice late eighties now that's
current he he still looks like he's 55
and he's just like acting like he's 30 I
hope I have that kind of energy yeah me
too before we let go ahead sorry go
ahead Brad I asked him what the secret
is on that hmm I asked to actually Liz
and she said denial denial denial denial
is that how these four young she's been
Eyal not as young as he says he is kind
of like you yeah just like me
I just have one more question because a
lot of the people who are listening to
this and who will watch the special it
starts with us singing a song or at
least when we taped it it did actually
it started when we taped it that way it
ends that way now oh yeah really well
because you remember the way we pay that
song mm-hmm yes and remember what I said
would be really cool yes right that
happened oh it okay with a certain okay
no sir there's even a certain religion
dari yeah
country star yeah yeah so we have
another cameo that was another
Kamio in there yeah she's at the end so
that was actually Netflix idea which is
a great idea nice a whole song at the
end a little so my question is do you
want John and I to come and do that song
with you at the CMAs this year and you
know we don't have to be a beginning not
on it probably won't be on camera okay
we'll just do it here in the studio and
send it it will email it to you you're
not even a fake camera and make us feel
like there's no film would be great
Wow hey let me ask you this because
we've been doing this with our little
podcast where we start off with a
question and just sort of so but that
way listeners get to know us or whatever
so the one we're going to do this
episode was like what's one of the
craziest weirdest bizarre venues you've
ever played you know I just performed in
Little Rock Arkansas for the first time
in a wrestling ring so that was a threat
Bling Ring yeah it was a recipe yeah I'm
surprised that's the first time it
happened I can't believe it oh my god
this might be a new trend why does that
make sense
go ahead don't know some about it like
it's almost Roman you know it's almost
like a gladiator yeah and yeah it's
theater-in-the-round
you know theater-in-the-round DK does it
anyway stand up especially a lot of
times he's in the round or something in
the middle walking around in the ends up
taking bread off and body slamming
somebody doesn't take a chair what about
you Brad have you ever performed in a
place weirdest yeah weird offend you I
mean I always hate I just hate
anything where they're eating why you're
my toaster yeah yeah Wow you know and I
can remember the kid that sort of just
like I had like you know you've made it
when you don't ask the question anymore
are they gonna be serving dinner during
the show right because there's just
nothing worse than getting up and
performing and there's people like
classing plates are
and you're not over word mister sleazing
yeah I mean it's one thing if you're a
jazz musician but it's a but when you're
up there like talking and singing and
time and you're and think about like
some of the songs like you know just
whiskey lullabye or something or people
are dying people are having their salad
while you write why you sentimental line
you hear some was like can you pass the
salt yeah i worse you know they're like
they're like pouring wine like he put
that bottle to his head and pulled the
trigger you know but that's always been
I mean I don't understand country music
is not good dinner music there's many
reasons yeah Wow well start now you
probably had to play a lot of crazy
little honky tonks and that kind of
stuff where there's lots of booze
flowing and you know always picture that
dark Lincoln around yeah yeah yeah I
mean that those don't though you know
there's something less sacred about that
you just don't expect you're not
expecting anybody to pay attention
anyway so we're just kind of at home huh
yeah and kids they're not paying I think
the worst the worst one I ever the worst
situation ever was the national anthem I
hate first of all national anthems
mm-hmm because singing singing those is
similar that's similar to singing a
wedding because I mean and I'll do it at
times but everybody like no one's there
to hear that that's it's a hard song
anyway it's actually yeah it's okay I
mean it's only hard because everybody
knows it
yeah and you can't smile and look at
people in the front row and get it right
and I don't they're not right oh he's
singing this verse different now you're
not yeah you can't change it but it's
similar
in the sense that people can't wait for
you to eat them and I don't like any gig
or people can't wait for you to be done
right and the worst one ever was a
hockey game in Wheeling West Virginia
the minor league teams called the
Washington or the Wheeling nailers
because they make nails and yeah - earth
down so they called the nailers that was
my nickname in high school
Baylor yeah that sarah nailer but I
walked out on the ice and they didn't
have like Corp it or anything like they
didn't roll it on a carpet or anything
on to the idea that you wouldn't post
you asked and I'm I walked out there in
cowboy boots laughing the national
anthem and the Spile a hit the hit the
microphone in the dead center like
center court and there was nobody there
until I slid in Oh plate because I just
took my buttons wait is there video of
that I know I need to see that now that
was like 91 they didn't people didn't
yeah well you dodged the bullet there oh
man that's that's one for them I don't
like to see that I could just imagine on
bone it's beautiful but I can't remember
walking out there like please welcome to
sing the national anthem local musician
as they're announcing me and I can I go
in a bet and as I'm going down I'm
thinking please get your head and I like
yeah at least a good question I don't
want to remember this ever happened well
that was 91 you said yeah yeah I want my
team that yeah yeah I was young I wanna
be so hard to sing to and you're trying
to keep your balance I would think well
does he get back up do this like they
all they did was sick of black
microphone stand
tripod in the middle of the ice with a
spotlight on it they set you up that's
cold that's right yeah oh my god there's
like just like roadies taking bets oh
that's amazing you're amazing I'm so
glad I can't believe you called in for
us and that's on ice and thank you for
letting me us be a part of this special
with you which comes out August 15th on
Netflix and it's called Brad Paisley's
comedy road a rodeo and you've done so
much for me until you guys believe you
did this - yeah thank you
see you guys did a great job on it and I
think it's going to be fun to see what
people think because I've watched the
whole thing after they got the Salette
it just and and really everything Lance
it's just really cool in the sense that
every it's got a laid back sort of feel
to it it's not you have some comedy
specials don't work because they it's
almost like they're trying too hard and
we we certainly work we get to do
another one I mean this is just a blast
and you're so funny yeah I think we will
I think that they're like we've talked
about I think there's a really fun
concept and taking over the way that
sometimes we'll go play music in a club
after a big concert like we'll take out
the local honky Tonk and just sing some
songs like the band and I think it's
same thing could be done at a comedy
club Blair know he's around and turn and
go - I've seen that the other day when
we when we first lost the tour in June
we were we were up in Saratoga Springs
New York and we had two days there his
we were rehearsing and one of the days I
was running around just going - I went
to a coffee shop and stuff and was kind
of jogging through this little town and
they had a comedy club in Saratoga which
was like wow this little
hole-in-the-wall in the downtown street
it looked like
it was like a thousand square-foot
comedy club yeah and I thought well this
would have been perfect perfect just the
play this first concert and all this go
back there and just yeah start comedy at
midnight and see what happens that would
be a fun little endeavor you know the
amount that we laugh and we're all just
hanging out just like screwing around
well that time at his house we all went
to rehearse was like a blast yeah you
know that was a man of itself you know
if that's all we had done oh that's
great would be a great way to open
trying to pitch oh yeah we should we
should just film that next time they're
like we need to cold up and I'm like you
should have filmed us sitting around
talking about what we would do for a
cold just pitching ideas to you is
always like so fun and funny because it
hates something you're like uh-huh yeah
maybe and that'll actually evaporate
pretty quickly because I'm eventually
Vista you'll get I'll get like I am with
you guys where I am with my co-writers
words like that's the dumbest need
you're awake to turn ghost in the corner
yeah it was really funny I felt like
John and I were coming in at such an
advantage to that filming because like
whenever the other guys wanted to ask
you something they would have us go ask
you they're like you guys go ask him
like we're too afraid
normal dude but I think like I said
we've we came in an advantage knowing
you before them and and we got to work
with you before so we know how you make
your such a relaxed guy and you make
everybody feel normal and I feel like
maybe we've really settled into that a
little too much remembering how famous
helped that I got a bunch of Bourbon
that was gonna say and he's really good
at pouring Guinness oh he's very good at
pouring goodness yeah there's a larger
art form to it you know
people might not know that he's really
good at porn gaming yeah I can pour agin
it I can do that very good thank you uh
that was amazing I can't believe you
stayed on with I know I've been keeping
him way too long yeah what's next for
you where you when you hang up the phone
what are you doing
pick it up dinner what are you having
Little Caesars we went to Chinese just a
normal guy the best Chinese is a mount
pilot everyone knows that please tell
Kim and the boys we say hello and I will
you're the best thank you so much we
look forward to seeing what happens on
August 15th thank you
I can't wait thanks for part of it thank
you holy [ __ ] what a good guy
well is there 30 minutes I didn't think
you'd stay on that long I thought for
5-10 minutes I know it's gonna waste
this time all the time just like let's
get these questions but then you don't
want to cut him off either
forget like I mean I mean I feel like I
know he's a normal guy and we you know
we've hung out with him quite a few
times and we know he's just like a
normal comic like he's just like hanging
out with any of the other comics but man
that was pretty amazing that he had just
hung out with us he does he's so good at
just hanging out yeah normal dude yeah I
always feel like he's he does so many
things right that thirty minutes is a
long time for him well when we were at
his house before the taping the night
before there were editing videos he was
doing a video for every single song yeah
it was releasing a new album that's 14
different music videos right yes is
insane right that's so many oh I mean
wow that's a lady that was Brad Paisley
everyone just in case you didn't know
who that was yeah that was an element
and this is our first ever fried podcast
well this is our first ever interview I
know it was
unless you kept my mom no your mom
that's that's not interview you're right
that's more of a report yes yeah John's
mom on the podcast will be is more of a
report it's a baby blues movie review
yes reviews for us and then we're also
gonna be doing we're gonna be doing lots
of fun stuff yeah we got tons of
segments we'd like to throw out there
what do you want to go to next to see
what you wait you know what wait we
never did answer the question about
what's the craziest venue you played it
and I'd I said mine I could elaborate
more on that and then you probably have
something crazy to some house in a
boxing ring which was pretty boxing and
Iraq well then that's well which is
pretty a ring is a ring yes did you have
the ropes up on the ropes breath okay
they used it it was really the only you
know have you've done military tours
overseas nope
never did well when you should a
military tour or even a CONUS like the
continental United States you'll you'll
perform in there MWR room yeah which is
stands for Morale Welfare recreation and
so usually when we were on tour we would
we would perform in wherever there MWR
room was okay this particular base and
their pie only about 200 people on the
base it was right on the Iran border and
all they had was a boxing ring and then
they had a couple decks of cards and
like I think a Scrabble game it was
literally I mean we we had come from
bases where they had you know golf range
hub set up to where it's like one of
those like green screen driving ranges
and tons of video games and a computer
lab this space did not have any of that
so for entertainment all they had was a
boxing ring a boxing man named rabble a
cars yes and they would they would do
scorpion fights in the ring and they
would like bet on them oh well and we
were literally the biggest entertainment
that they had had their entire stay Wow
and and they brought all of their
Humvees and tanks around the ring and
they sat on top of them like a NASCAR
race with like chairs and then they were
a bunch of chair set up in front for
like you know
that's cool and yeah we performed right
there performed on the back of the truck
there I was gonna say when he was
talking about performing when dinner
served or whatever yeah we had a
gentleman all the time which reminded me
of a gig that you told me about one time
in a lunchroom oh yeah where there was
no one there right they didn't know
you're coming out it's like when so when
you're a comedian and you would do these
colleges half the time you do a college
they forget that you're even coming so
colleges booked entertainment because
they get a certain budget every year if
they don't use that budget they don't
get that same budget the next year right
so they really don't have an incentive
to go they just have incentive to use
the budget right so really you're just
there getting a paycheck which helps
them get that same money the next year
for maybe a comedian they really got
well we spend every dime yeah one cook
so now we're just gonna get ten people
right who we don't really care about
just so we can try to get Dane Cook next
year exactly and so I would I showed up
at this it was it was at Penn State York
which was yeah out in Amish country in
Pennsylvania it was at noon in a
lunchroom
I was opening up for a band and I had to
do you know like an hour and like
everybody's coming in was the stage
already set for the band there was a
stage set up so I was like performing in
front of the bands drum kids whatever
and I mean it's like people are talking
the whole time just like uh-uh
so whatever radio is on is very loud
during our conversation and I'm like you
know what I just got to get through this
because that's what I'm paid to do yeah
it's it's hell but you you told me once
that yeah yeah yeah you went to do this
college and the night before you had
open for dawei yeah we talked about this
on the show Oh Dwight Yoakam II you told
me this story and I told this story to
other comics when they are sad about a
gig they just did I go let me talk about
this gay John Reith dead yeah and I'll
tell it for you the night before John
has opened up her to white Yocum he
comes to do this gig at a college he
shows up he can't find the lady in
charge finally finds her and she goes oh
that's right the
median there's a mic there's a
microphone in the lunchroom just get out
of the closet plug it in just go do your
hour come back and I'll give you your
chest right it was it's really it was
okay I mean you showed up and there are
three kids on fire instead they're not
even together yeah
spread out but you gathered them
together I mess up guys huh
I apologize to him I said I know you're
not here to see me I know you're
probably studying for a test that's
coming up but I'm being forced to talk
out loud for one hour I have to do I
have to do this and if you you know I
understand if you want to leave mm-hmm
you may leave I'm Andy and then they
said what what what is it and then I
said well come over here I don't want to
yell at you then I just got them all to
sit at one table and we sat down but
didn't you convince them to go
underneath I did at some point I did
because I had a wireless mic uh-huh
I didn't even need a microphone I mean
the first 20 minutes was me just talking
to them like what are you gonna do for
Christmas you know what are you doing an
act I was just talking to them you don't
have to do the act I don't care about
your then we then we had fun with the
wireless mic because because it was a
big cafeteria and people would come in
randomly to go to a soda machine or you
know I said let's get on the table and
pretend to be the Machine at soccer
station so I got another table and then
walk up with a dollar be like please
insert one dollar speaker was like it's
the speaker in the room it was like a
part of that you know so I guess I kind
of believed it we had fun with the
hidden camera prank show for no reason
but I'm so that inspired me to always
like think about the situation and just
adapt and I think as a community an
you're constantly having to adapt to a
wrestling ring yeah that was that was
weird
so why were you in a wrestling ring okay
so I got hired to do this game there's a
some local DJs in Little Rock Arkansas
who have been putting on this gig
they're aspiring comics the husband and
wife else every morning radio show and
they've been putting on this show a
stand-up show to raise money for some I
forgot what the charity was DJ's without
jokes yeah and so it was a charity thing
plus a fundraiser but all that together
they always bring a comedian and a
headliner and they and they want to open
it you know so they work as a promoter
and they have at different places and
this this year they had at this place
called the Metroplex a big Events Center
which has all kinds of events that come
in their music you know wrestling and so
it just so happened to be that the next
couple days after my performance was
wrastlin and so they they already had
this thing set up but they said well
we're gonna take the ropes out so they
can see you so they took the ropes off
the ring but but I'm standing in the
ring doing jokes you know and they had
little cameras set up on each little
corner so that when I my back is turned
then the other crowd can only see my
face on the big screen that's above my
head it was bizarre it was bizarre do
you when you're in a situation like that
do you tell a joke about the situation
in the situation just to let everybody
know I do a I know I'm in a wrestling
almost you kind of have to otherwise you
look like an idiot
yeah right so I kind of weather said
well this is the first for me I've never
performed in a wrestling ring before or
indoors of people at all so I pretended
to do like this little wrestling move a
couple times though every time I do a
joke that would that would kill I would
pretend that you know so drop of the mic
or don't think I would I would run up
against these fake ropes or out there
and do you normally drop the mic no no I
don't know what I normally do but I
pretended it was a thing they always do
but it seemed to work they like it this
is the only ring I'm ever gonna get so
it was because you'd see people like in
that kind of environment it's it's it's
okay to get up and in the middle of a
joke and go pee or randomly lean over
talk to your friend cuz there it's set
up for wrestling and wrestling you're
allowed to talk to your neighbors you
know your people around you or you know
they weren't like you had to really get
their attention from the to pay
attention because a minute you turned
your back on that side this eye starts
to get in talk again so you had to like
I literally had to walk around it was
weird like I felt like Chris Rock he's
always pacing except I was just doing
laps well I would also say that
performing with Brad at the
Wood Bowl might be one of the other
craziest places by far yeah it's
definitely the most I'm sure pop it up
with him iconic legendary place that
I've ever performed you know we were
only the fourth and fifth comedians ever
on that stage is that right yeah all of
the other people who were then there
were Eddie Murphy well for Steve Martin
Eddie Murphy and Eddie Izzard no kid
that's it Wow me and time check that off
yeah sorry Louie CK the next night Eddie
Izzard was playing there oh that's right
that's right I went to see him and I
went with my friend Michael Cox who
books the night show and at the time he
was booking Chelsea which is why I knew
him I definitely would never have known
him if he had always been booking me and
then we walked in I just like all day I
was waiting and I walked in to get our
seats and I said oh this is what it
looks like from the audience perspective
like I've only ever been on stage at the
Hollywood Bowl I've never sat in the
audience point of view yeah he was like
it's funny that I remember like not I
survived if I tell people how did you
how did you perform it's kind of like oh
I survived it you know for me it was
well as Maya is my fault because I told
Brad would be funny if he just if I
walked out there and pretend to be a
roadie and test the minor and then just
start doing my set as opposed to being
introduced right so when I walked out
there that wasn't like ladies and
gentlemen and a good friend of Brad
Paisley please pay attention clap your
hands for Jon REEP there was nothing
like that which would have helped then
he introduced no one introduced me oh go
ahead oh yeah I walked out there I
walked up to the mic like just one check
one check one Kenny Chesney's not here
just a bum concert and I walk over to
another mic and I do another Mic Check
and then I can y'all hear me in the back
and they're like yeah I was like cool
man then I just start talking I just
started getting my set but it was weird
because I never done that before
it's not something I'm used to doing and
that's the first time I've done it and
that was at the Hollywood
I took a good three minutes to get
everyone's attention killer okay this
guy's a state but we also like we came
out together at the very beginning yeah
we were gonna be doing but the time I
got back up nobody yeah it was totally
dark and as a whole new crowd right it
was full see when I went out so we went
out there together then Mickey Gaiden
came out that's right
and then so Brad introduced me right and
then you came and I came when it's still
light outside right and I was like you
know what I'm just gonna play to the
people in the front cuz I guarantee you
know it's 17,000 seats for people who
haven't been there and you know and it's
an amphitheater so sound actually
travels really well I guess comedians
will tell you that doing comedy outside
in front of a band is usually horrible
because the laughter just dissipates
immediately but this was different it
was like it was all held in and might as
well been indoors yeah and and so I
walked out and I was like I'm just gonna
play the people in front just gonna do
I'm doing five minutes or whatever just
just while so basically John and I were
there as the bands were resetting right
so they're setting up Justin more behind
me while I perform right and then I was
like I just remember the very went the
second joke I told was my dad's a really
tough guy he fought during the Vietnam
War and the joke is mostly in bars with
his friends cuz I did not go and I said
my dad's really tough guy because he
fought during the Vietnam War everyone
applauded and then I said you know
mostly in bars and everybody laughed and
at that moment I just relaxed and I was
like I can do whatever I want and also
Brad's wife Kim was there and and we
admit Kim before and so I just I looked
at her too and I kind of like relaxed
when I'm looking at her because I know
that she's like such a hot you know a
good judge of con if she's laughing I
feel like yeah everybody else will be
laughing so I caught her for a second I
was like okay everything's gonna be all
right
yeah and
as I you know yeah you did great all
right okay but I mean literally there
you had twice as many people there when
you went up and no introduction no
internet like I met your crowd in the
front row was laughing I remember one
guy go I know you
Nord him well he would he even know as a
comedian he does anyway like I said I
survived well but they're on a golf
stage it was I do that was great
and I always think it's horrible when
you yeah of course well compared if
you're comparing it to normal club gig
right literally it was people there to
see you a month later I got asked to
open for a wreath of Franklin which is
like what but apparently she's with our
same agency who was also Brad's agent
you know and they're like she wanted a
comedian because they're cheaper and pay
for a band right and it was like no
money and it was at the Santa Barbara
out ampitheatre and they were like well
we need a comic who has experience
outdoors at an amphitheater and I had
just done the Hollywood Bowl so they're
like well we'll get Sarah that's
experience and it was literally one of
the worst like I did 25 minutes I show
up it's just me and Aretha Franklin on
the bill it says Sarah Tiana Aretha
Franklin backstage right like the good
old days right like like just our normal
tour okay and I mean I guess they have
no idea comedians coming out it's not
like Brad Brad put an announcement yeah
yeah you know oh my god that's something
they gotta learn to do I mean you gotta
make it easy for us he's right there
like if we started out just like hanging
out after his concerts at a comedy club
and just [ __ ] around slowly people
this Netflix thing hopefully they don't
see okay this is something he kind of
does yeah but that's the thing is like I
don't know if yeah it's we have to wrap
it up but I don't know if you if people
have said it to you but they're just
like why does Brad pay you really have a
Netflix special too and I'm like it's
him introducing us honestly but also we
know how funny is I forget that other
people don't realize why not Brett I
mean he could do anything he wants he's
huge people will watch it just to see
him that was out of there I was going to
say to him was that I wonder if the
reason him and
Manning have such an okay time making
fun of themselves if it's because
they're so hugely famous but they're
like yeah you can make fun of me all you
want I'm still gonna go back to my third
Manchester now yeah now it's a little
bit easier was amazing we this is our
first episode that you've ever heard
yeah normally not like this we tell you
that we have segments normally our
episodes but we just got really carried
away with your ad and we're very excited
about this special it's been something
that we've been wanting to promote for
so long now we're so excited it's about
to come out so August 15th on Netflix
please tune in let us know what you
think good or bad we just want to hear
yeah go to our little social websites um
you know whatever you're on I'm on it to
you what are the Facebook Instagram
Twitter is everything is just Jo in our
eep Jon REEP find me email me let me
know what you think I'm sure the same
thing yeah Jon does not have an H in his
name I do she took money I took the H
it's Sarah with an H Tiana with the
Tiana that's the same on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and let us know we're
on the road all the time doing touring
this week so the week of the 15th so
it'll be the 16th through the 20th I'll
be in st. Louis at the funny bone nice I
will be at a place called the orange
peel in Asheville North Carolina August
12 and 25 yeah so check that out Myrtle
Beach at the end of that weekend and uh
should we wrap it up I think we should
wrap it up how do we have anything else
that you want it to let's let them know
that we got some DNA results that are
coming out we've got some segments a
small town a hometown news sort of stuff
my mother will be calling in doing some
movie reviews you get to hear my mom
meet her my dad give us a pics so thanks
for bearing with us we hope that you
will continue to listen to fried with
Jon REEP and Sarah Tiana
the shade of a Georgia pine and that's
home you know sweet why me why me why me
why me why